All right. Thanks everybody for joining,
uh, kind of the holdouts for some of the last sessions, so
I really appreciate it. I also know that I'm competing with a keynote,
so I'm very happy to have you here.
Uh, my name is Justin Rio, I'm deputy CTO
at DX. Uh, DX is
a productivity platform, an engineering intelligence
platform,
uh, and we're able to look at a lot of insights
around how various things, tools,
technology, and things like that
are impacting productivity within an
organization. Right. And so this is
where the data
that you're about to see kind of from this study
came from.
Uh, we're able to pull insights from
over 135,000 developers
who are tracking AI utilization within
the platform
across 435 companies.
Uh, we've looked at engineering org sizes
from less than 50 engineers to over
10,000 engineers, and we'll break some
of that data down in this study.
And we're looking at regional global companies,
so headquarters in North America, LATAM.
Europe and Asia Pacific.
So this is aggregated anonymized
data, and we use
various reporting mechanisms to get this data
into the system.
Part of what DX is really good at is marrying
qualitative signals
from high performing surveys, like 90%
plus participation rate in these surveys,
uh, the types of surveys that are engineered to
kind of look at developer experience as a systems
problem, not a people problem.
So we tend to get very honest responses.
Uh, so as far as I know, this is probably the the
best data set that's kind of available right now,
uh, in terms of how AI is truly
impacting uh work across different
cohorts and different kinds of companies.
So that's what we'll share today.
Now there's a full report
that dives deeper into some of this,
uh, which you are of course welcome to download.
I'm gonna share a few resources with you
throughout the course of this presentation,
um. So, and we have plenty of time. I
think this is like an hour long session.
Uh, so I'll I'll linger a little bit on some
of these slides.
Uh, this is the result of compiling
a lot of this data.
Myself and my um
CTO counterpart Laura Taco, who some of you
may know, she, she's very prolific in the developer
experience space, uh, worked together to
put this, uh, to put this guide and these various
kind of figures together.
Um, so there's a lot in there, it's much more meaty
than what we'll get into today,
um, but we're gonna cover, uh, some of the trends
and some of the interesting,
uh, details that came out in this report.
All right, so first of all,
let's talk a little bit about
the current impact of AI,
right? Where are we?
Uh, nobody knows.
So, you know, on the one hand,
we've got Google telling us like, oh, we're, you know,
our engineers are 10% more productive
as a result of of using AI. Now of
course Google's already a highly productive company,
focused a lot on developer productivity. They were
pioneers in the study of developer experience.
But on the other hand, we have this now I would say sort
of infamous
METR study, meter study, which had some flaws,
you know, don't get me wrong.
That showed that developers who took part in
that study were 19%
less productive as a result
of using AI, and this is cursor. Now
there were 16 people in this study.
Some of them had never even touched cursor before, so
that's flawed. But the one takeaway that I do
think is really interesting from this study
is that every engineer in that
study qualitatively felt.
That they were more productive using
AI. So I think that there's something about
the tooling that's kind of fun.
It kind of initiates a bit of a flow state, makes
us feel like we're doing more work, but in this
case, in this study,
it didn't really turn out that way.
So we have a lot of data, uh, let me
get ahead of myself here. Dora also, uh,
you know, produces a lot of great reports. We work
with Dora very closely. In fact, Nicole
Forsgren, who invented the Dora metrics
and wrote the book Accelerate,
uh, is one of our chief researchers.
Uh, she and my CEO Abby Noda
just recently released a book called Frictionless,
um, which talks about sort of a playbook for developer
experience.
So we work very, very closely with the Dora community. I
have a lot of great friends there, they do a lot of great work.
Uh, this data though,
tended to like report
impact
on averages.
So we're seeing these sort of like
modest but positively leaning
gains from this study. 7.5%
increase in documentation quality,
3.4% increase in code
quality, so at least,
you know, not a huge leap, but at least not leaning in the
in the in the wrong direction, right?
3.1% increase in overall code
review speed.
Uh, so again, like these modest,
but at least positively leaning
metrics that we're looking at
across broad averages.
So then we thought, well, why don't we correlate that data and see what we
found, and we found largely the same thing.
So this was a sample of close to 20,000
developers,
and this metric is
called change confidence.
It's a qualitative metric,
and it's measured on a top box Leichhardt
score. So what is that? If you're not familiar with survey
engineering, a Leichhardt scale is when
you say answer a question, like always, very often,
sometimes, you know,
and the top box scoring methodology means
we want to see the percentage of people who answered always
or very often,
right? So the two like positive answers that
you can put in that survey. So what you're seeing here
is a percentage of developers that effectively
answered a question saying that they feel like they can put
stuff into production without breaking things.
And uh what you're seeing here is AI users on
the left
and non-AI users on the right, in the platform.
And there's a 2.6% gain
from using AI. OK, yeah, great. Again,
not huge, but at least positively
leaning. We see the same thing with
code maintainability, another quality metric,
how much cognitive load do you feel like you have
to expend to understand the code that's in
front of you. Uh, and we found a
2.2% gain amongst
AI users that they felt, uh, you
know, that they, that the code itself was maintainable.
Easy to read. OK, cool.
Then we looked at, uh, change failure rate,
you know, who's familiar with Dora metrics and change
failure rate and stuff like that. I got a few of you, so change
failure rate is kind of what it sounds like, the percentage
of value adding features, uh, that you
release that then have to be reverted because they
break something.
And we saw a 0.11% reduction
from using AI.
OK, you know,
the, the industry benchmark is 4%.
So as sort of insignificant as that seems when
you compare it to a 4% benchmark, it's a little
bit more significant.
So then we thought, well
This can't be right,
because we're talking to customers that are experiencing
good things,
and we're talking to customers that are experiencing bad
things. So I thought, what if we ran the
sample and we reported it company per
company instead?
Here's what we saw
OK,
every bar
represents a single company on this graph.
You want to be on the top line here. This means
some companies experiencing more
than a 20%
increase in change confidence,
but also companies experiencing a 20%
decrease.
So when we look at the averages, when we filter
by average,
the data, that's not telling us the story of what's really
happening, right? We're actually living in quite
volatile times. Now, there's
a lot of factors that go into
this. There's something that we're starting to
refer to as agent X or agent
experience, which is effectively that what's good for
humans is also good for agents.
And so companies that have already spent a lot of time.
Like perfecting their automation and doing
a lot of work on their SDLC and and getting
all the right code hygiene things, they tend to
be obviously on the top line of this graph.
The irony is that all of this investment
in AI and agents and everything might finally
get companies unified about caring about the
things that we should have been doing for developers
er years ago.
Um, so we looked at, we saw the same thing with
code maintainability.
Same volatility here.
Uh, we saw the same thing with change failure rate.
Um,
so and this is a 2%
increase, you wanna be on the bottom side of this
graph here, you want to decrease your change failure
rate. A 2% increase in
change failure rate
across a 4% benchmark
means shipping 50% more
defects
than you were before.
But then same here at the bottom, shipping 50%
less, right?
So, a big takeaway here
is that especially as leaders, like we've got to
measure, right? We need to
understand where we are. And if we're on the
wrong side of this graph, we need to be
really strategic in thinking about how we get on the
right side of it.
Because as everyone knows, right, AI is an accelerant,
it accelerates good
and it accelerates bad, right?
And we are seeing absolutely widespread
adoption. One thing that is definitely consistent.
Is that we're seeing now 90%
overall adoption of AI
across the companies that we sampled. This was a
broad sample of 135,000
developers,
um, and we're getting from light utilization.
On the lower end of the scale,
uh, to more moderate and then high
utilization. So this is basically
monthly,
weekly, daily, is kind of the scale
there. All right. So this has all happened very
quickly,
uh, and we're going to talk about how this is
like reported metrics,
but that it's probably more like 100%,
and I'll show you that in a minute.
Um, we're finding that across again a
broad sample of engineers, the regular
AIs, uh, AI users are saving about 3.8
hours a week,
uh, from code completion and that sort of thing.
This isn't, um, also talking about
integrating agents throughout the SDLC, that's
a whole other topic.
I do have some data on that as well.
But this is really like the code completion thing.
So, OK, you know, 3.8 hours a week.
I think it's also very important though to remember
that like,
You know, the, the Dora state of developer Experience
report that just came out still reported that
engineers on average, because of so many other
time syncs and stuff, are lucky
to get 5 to 6 hours a week
of like focused time
writing code.
So as impressive as this is,
it's not necessarily the bottleneck, I think for most
organizations, right? But this is what we're seeing across a
broad sample.
Um,
22% of code across
this sample is now authored by
AI,
right? And when we looked at the sampling.
Uh, we were very careful not to just look at telemetry
metrics here,
right, because telemetry metrics don't always tell the
full story. When we get a little later in this
presentation to measurement,
I'll talk about sort of the three types of metrics
that you want to correlate together to
get a good picture about impact.
Um, but in this case, like for instance,
how do we know that if an engineer like
accepted the code changes, that didn't just go and then
rewrite every line of it afterwards, right?
So that would mean like the code didn't actually
make it from AI to production. This is
code that made it from AI to production,
right? And we have some technology that's coming out
soon, uh, where we look at
various hashes and things like that going on in the file
system to be able to automate this.
Um, but this is the data that we found
right now.
OK. Uh, daily
AI users are shipping 60%
more PRs.
Now, what's in those PRs,
right?
We know that we have companies that are,
uh, you know, mandating top-down
use of AI
just like we always sort of tell people not
to focus on any single metric.
100% utilization across the company
doesn't really say anything,
especially if there's a mandate to do it, and
especially if that mandate is being weaponized
or incentivized,
because there's this little thing called Goodheart's law.
Uh, I'm from the South,
and we say, uh, when you're talking about developer
experience, you can't swing a dead cat without coming across
Goodheart's law.
Uh, anybody familiar with that law?
A couple of you. All right. It basically says that when a
measure
becomes a target,
it ceases to be a good measure,
right? And the reason for that is
because we're humans, and especially as
engineers, we're going to find a way to hit that metric,
right? If, if we're told that we need 100%
utilization across the company to to use
AI, like, OK, we will
update our read me file every morning, like using
an assistant, and we will look like we've got 100%
utilization.
There's a great parable that goes alongside
Goodheart's law called the Cobra effect. Anybody
heard of that one?
OK, so
it's a good way to explain it. It's a silly
story. Uh, you have an emperor
who has a problem with venomous cobras
in the kingdom,
and so, uh, sets up an incentivization
program, hey, bring me 100 dead cobras, and
I'll give you some money.
Alright, so I'm incentivizing now the number of dead
cobras that you bring me.
So some people got clever, what do you think they did? They started
farming cobras
and killing them and bringing them to the emperor, right,
so we're gaming the system.
Emperor gets wind of what's going on, the people are cheating,
kills the program.
And all those farmers release
all those cobras, and the problem
gets a lot worse, right?
So, um,
we do have to be careful about what's in these PRs, but
we do know that it's definitely accelerating. So
you're seeing it's going from daily to weekly to monthly
to never, so
very satisfying
kind of graph there. And then an area that
we have,
uh,
um, no data.
I want to point out, because we're going to get back to this.
That the metrics showed us that people who are never
using AI
are using AI to ship 1.3%
or 1.3 extra PRs. Uh,
so we'll get into that in a moment.
Uh, OK, so that's just kind of what we've
seen in terms of current impact. This is all very
fresh data, by the way. Uh, we ran
these samples back in mid-October.
Now I know that things are moving very quickly,
um, but this isn't like some study we did like a year ago.
Uh, we'll continue to put out these types of reports
at least quarterly.
Uh, we've built sort of a mechanism to do that,
uh, and it's pretty easy for us to, to glean this
data. So keep an eye out on stuff that we continue to push.
Alright, some interesting trends though.
Junior engineers are actually using AI the most.
So we're seeing junior engineers here on the left,
mid-level senior and then staff plus.
Um so,
and then these, these darker areas are daily
active use, right? So we see junior engineers
actually making use of this technology.
Now, I've been writing code professionally since the
late 90s, OK. I, I was just
as reticent, you know, I've been a staff engineer,
and I've been through that whole like, oh, I can't
do it better than me, I should write the code, or I like writing
code and You know, I've, I've come around to
the fact that like
the optimization of developer experience and
productivity has always been about reducing toil,
right? And it, and in my opinion,
It now sort of behooves us to rethink
that definition of toil,
right? Like if there is something like writing mid-loop
code, like I, I know my function header, I know
what my function's supposed to do.
Do I really need to write the code in
between? What if you like coding? Great. Work
on an open source project, work on a passion
project, but if somebody's paying you
to write code efficiently.
You know, we have to get to a point where,
you know, we can at least trust some of these things that
work well,
much better than they did like a year ago,
uh, over to some of these agents and these assistants.
But I think with junior engineers, you don't have that much of a
problem, right, because it's, they're still learning newer
skill sets,
right? So it's interesting to see, um,
to see these adoption trends,
uh, and I imagine that we'll see this change over time,
you know, I mean, I was definitely one of a
skeptic before I kind of became a believer, and
I think a lot of people are kind of going through that journey right now.
Uh, so staff engineers though,
interestingly, save the most time.
So even though they're lagging in overall adoption,
they're generally going to be better at understanding
when code is well written,
when it's ready to ship,
right, when there's issues with the code,
and so they're going to be more efficient in these tools
once they start getting better at them.
We have definitely realized a trend
across the board. This is like almost every company
that we sampled, and it didn't matter whether you're a
junior engineer or a senior engineer.
There's absolutely this sort of J curve, that
when we move from no adoption
to light adoption, and if you're a leader in the audience,
you kind of have to be ready for this.
During that none to light adoption phase,
productivity across the board went down,
and so did quality.
And then we moved into moderate and heavy adoption,
it outpaced where we were before.
But it was such a clear indicator
of this like experimentation and learning
period. Like it's really necessary to
allow engineers to get
the right type of education material, have
time to implement that education, have
time to experiment,
and just, just expect that things might get a little bit
worse before they do start getting better,
right? Uh,
so I do think it's interesting though that then when we see
these heavy users
of
AI on the staff engineering side,
we're outpacing senior and mid-levels
with this, with this heavy adoption. So
even though staff engineers might be slower
to adopt the technology, when they
do, they end up saving more time, they end up actually
being better with it.
So something to think about there too, if you're having
Uh, still having some reticence in the
organization, and you don't want to drive the top-down mandate
for all those reasons that I just said,
but you do want to encourage all of your engineers
to be able to take advantage of great new
technology and to be able to learn new skill sets that
are in all likelihood going to benefit them from the rest of
their careers,
right? So here's some data to
suggest that when
us uh stodgy
staff engineers actually do start using this stuff the
right way, we, we actually have better results
with it. Um,
this is pretty interesting too.
We saw that traditional enterprises actually
have higher,
uh, daily AI usage.
We saw smaller companies, and I'll show that
in a minute,
start adopting the technology sort of faster.
But, um, I just did a, a
read out on another Dora report,
uh, literally in a panel like like 3 hours
ago. That talked about
one of the biggest indicators for like the
good use of AI
and some of you I'm sure are starting to come across this,
is like clear AI policies
and basic change management.
And this is something that a lot of enterprises have
already sort of perfected.
So even though they might be a little slower on the rollout
and things like that,
the by the time they roll it out, there's higher
usage, and I think that that's because
um of enterprises already having a lot of
health around change management and
around clear AI policies. Um.
It's a really good report by Dora,
that has like a, it's called a Bayesian
posterior distribution graph,
and it's like kind of like these
hills with a dotted line in the middle. And
the the graph kind of tells you
where you're going to see positive or negative impact
across certain things, in this case with the use of AI
and you want to be like on the right side of the dotted
line. And you want this sharp kind
of peak, because that sharp peak means that we have a lot
of confidence in the data in that part of the
report. And like mandatory training,
clear AI policies,
and time to learn an experiment were by far
the leading indicators of people having
a lot of health in the implementation of this stuff.
And I think that again, that's something that's easier for
enterprises to be able to initiate
because they already have that kind of stuff. Like they
already have these kind of programs that are in place and
being used at scale.
So it was interesting to see this. We, we, um,
when Laura and I first kind of found this data, we were like, nah,
that can't be right.
But then we really started, I mean we resampled and resampled
and we're like this is what the data is showing. But
then when we really started thinking about it, and we started
thinking about these variables, it kind of
did become, you know, started to make sense.
However, small companies are the smaller
AI companies are using AI more frequently, right?
So we see like the uh
uh the heavy adoption
with uh companies that are less than
50 employees or 50 engineers,
uh, are the ones that are reaching that heavy
adoption phase faster, right?
Um, so again, I mean, that's also
not too surprising, right? Small, scrappy, not
a lot of clear AI policies,
this may not even necessarily be a good thing,
you know, I mean like the unregulated.
And unmonitored use of AI at scale
can really bite us, can get us on the bottom side of that graph
that we showed earlier, OK?
So I think there's something uh interesting to
consider there. Uh,
so again, kind of within that
um like that use that we see
coming out of enterprises, it was also very
interesting that um
enterprises were leading in actual time
savings. So when we actually start looking at
the output metrics themselves,
and we figure out like,
you know, what, what actually
has been the impact.
All of these things like clear policies,
like education, like all this stuff means
that there's more efficacious use of
AI
in enterprises. So we're seeing like
companies below 50,
this is
effectively the amount of additional PRs
that they're shipping.
Uh, sorry, this is the hours that they're actually saving,
and we see enterprises over here on the
right, uh, with 1,000+ engineers
actually saving the most hours per week once
they reach that sort of heavy adoption phase.
Um, you know, there's some interesting trends here
too, where we see these, um, you know, 500
to 1000 engineers with light
usage, uh, actually kind
of lagging, right?
Um, but yeah, very interesting data here too.
But I think again, more food for thought that like.
Going back to the first principles, the code hygiene,
the compliance, the change management, like all
these things are incredibly important for getting the
most ROI and the best
impact out of AI.
All right, so, back to that graph
where we said people that were never using AI were
shipping an additional PR week using
AI, right?
Um, I think what's going on here,
uh, and you're probably seeing this within your own
organization. What we were reporting
on were like enterprise APIs
and telemetry coming out from enterprise APIs,
meaning enterprise licenses, right?
So if you bought
enterprise co-pilot or cursor or something
like that, the only metrics, the only uh
usage that we're really able to get from a systems
perspective is the telemetry coming out of those APIs.
But remember I said before that DX captures
qualitative and quantitative metrics.
So what this was, was saying that even though
the licenses didn't show that
there was utilization of AI,
we still had qualitative signals coming
from people who were not using AI, quote unquote,
you know, talking about significant time savings
in what they're doing.
So this is like 11%
merged code.
That was qualitatively reported as
being written by AI
by people who, according to the API had
never used
AI, right? So these are personal
licenses for a cursor or people
pumping stuff into Chat GPT,
um, but this is something that really like,
we're gonna have to get a handle on this, right? I mean,
I am by no means a proponent of
a single solution, you know, I think we need to
be using multiple solutions, especially in enterprises
right now where some of these procurement cycles can take.
You know, 9 months to a year to actually roll
something out, and by the time you do, like 3
other technologies have leapfrogged it, I mean, things are just moving
too quickly for that right now.
But we are going to have to kind of unify if
we really want to understand utilization,
when we get into measurement in a moment, I'll
talk about why that's important.
The best way to measure this stuff is
to correlate utilization, daily
active weekly use amongst cohorts
to our core and foundational productivity
metrics that we've been able to trust for a long time,
right? So our Dora, our space, our DevEx, our core
four metrics, right? We want to see how utilization
in these cohorts impacts
those, those other metrics, but we'll get into that
in a little bit.
I just think it's very interesting
to kind of see this data play out. This is one of those
areas where
although system metrics are certainly important.
We need context coming from qualitative
metrics to really understand like the full
picture. Uh, we like to use a lot of health metaphors
at DX, so it's kind of akin to like,
you go to the doctor and you don't feel well, and
you tell them I don't feel well, and then they take your pulse and your
blood pressure, and they're like, well, you're, you're fine, all your metrics
are, yeah, but I don't feel well, right? Like the context
is very. Important there.
And this is one of those areas where we're able to kind of
pinpoint pretty clear
shadow AI usage as a result of
marrying telemetry and API metrics
with qualitative and self-reported metrics. And
let me be clear too, we're talking about surveys with 90%
plus participation rates. These are like
strong signals.
Uh, no big surprise here.
AI is delivering bigger gains in modern
languages, right? So we see like Golang,
Python, Rust, JavaScript here
on the left.
On the right we see poor old Cobalt.
I was actually just talking to a new friend
of mine from Atlassian. DX was acquired
by Atlassian back on the 10th of this
month. Uh, and they needed
somebody to ask them
to, uh, effectively
figure out
whether, uh, in this case, RoboDev
would be capable of an end to end conversion of
cobalt code
to Java code.
So he needed a demo for this.
Turns out, there's a Minecraft server
coded in cobalt,
an open source one.
And so he used that to start doing it and, you know,
uh it's much better at interpreting.
Um,
uh, Morgan Stanley has been very public
about their creation of an AI agent called
DevGen AI.
Uh, and what DevGen AI does is reverse
engineering of legacy code.
So you can imagine Morgan Stanley has a bunch of legacy
code laying around, they got mainframe natural,
they have Cobalt. I hate to admit it because I used to
write a lot of Perl, but Perl
considered legacy now.
Rather than a full end to end translation
solution though,
because it's difficult to get the full, you know, context
and everything like that from Cobalt.
They're just creating developer specs from all this
legacy code, right? So the, the, the
bots seem to be better at at least interpreting cobalt
than necessarily transcribing it, right?
Um, but yeah, this is across 23,500
developers over 48 companies,
and we again see that as the languages get
a little bit older,
um, the, the AI is just not as,
as good, and that's because of the stuff that it was trained
on. Um, also, some of it
is like thinking about the domain specific
specificity of some of these languages, like for
instance, JavaScript, like of course React and
TypeScript is like works pretty well
with these assistants,
because it's just code that's running in the browser, right? Even
if you're writing like crazy JavaScript
that's somewhat. Domain specific.
The semantics of the code itself are still bounded
and standardized by the
DOM and the browser itself,
right? So the AI doesn't, it's,
it's much different than trying to interpret
and understand a bunch of backend code that might
have a lot of domain specific semantics and things like
that. But yeah, pretty satisfying
graph here too,
but I wouldn't say terribly surprising.
This one's big
Uh, there's a significant
impact on just overall
onboarding,
right? So what this is, is across 14,000
developers, the number of days that it took to onboard
a new resource either into a
like an organization or a project.
And I mean, look at this rampdown.
Coming from back in Q1 of 2024,
before AI has sort of like, you know, begun to proliferate,
you know, we're looking at
this 78 day ramp
time. And we have more than cut that
in half now, on average.
Uh, Zapier, uh, is,
in my opinion, doing really, really well
with AI agents, which shouldn't like surprise
anybody, they're like an automation first company.
But I got a chance to speak to one of the folks who
works on, you know, building agents and AI
for Zapier,
and um they've done all kinds of stuff. They, they
love to joke that they've got more bots than humans at Zapier
and everything like that. They have a really nice grassroots
program for building agents.
And one of the things that they've been able to do is move their onboarding
time from 30 days down to 2 weeks,
right, so effective time from an engineer now coming
in uh less than half of what it was
before. They're also able to get about 15%
more productivity out of every engineer.
So they're doing what I think everybody should be doing. They're
hiring more,
right? They know that they can make these resources
more valuable,
faster,
and then they know that they can get more return on investment out
of a single hire.
So they're hiring faster than they ever have.
Right? Now I mean I talk a lot, I have other workshops
where I talk about the importance of psychological safety
and the adoption of AI.
And one big bit of uh psychological
safety is making sure that as leaders, we are very clear,
like we are augmenting
with this technology,
right? This technology is not ready to
replace. And I can cite multiple examples
of companies that have been very public about saying
we're gonna fire half our engineers,
and then we're gonna replace them with agents.
And it doesn't work, and then they have to rehire
those folks, but no one wants to work for them because they ruin
their reputation by hire by firing everybody,
right? We have to really remember now that this
is about augmentation, but this is a perfect
example of how we can really get more value, how we can make
a resource
by using agents and using various forms of AI
more valuable to the company more quickly. And
I think Zapier is an excellent example of that. I'll have
a newsletter article coming about coming
out about that interview pretty soon.
Um, but I really do think that that's, it was very inspirational
and even refreshing for me to kind of
talk to that person and hear that coming from, from
Zapier.
OK.
We're also having to redefine
the notion of a builder
in the organization, right? So traditional non-builders
now are shipping much more code.
We're seeing engineering managers actually shipping twice
as much code uh as they were as a
result of AI.
Um, this is also being reflected
as I look at a moment like project managers and stuff, but
we have to start rethinking like who's a developer,
right? Um,
you know, when you have project managers that are able to crank
out like decent prototypes.
When you have engineering managers that can now like
take on a player-coach role, but
like not in a bad way where they're overwhelmed,
you know, where they're actually getting a chance to contribute to code
bases along with uh managing teams,
that's, that's a fundamentally different world.
And I think makes for a better manager,
right? I mean somebody who's going to be able to kind of
understand, you know, the weeds of what's going on
and actually be able to contribute,
uh, I think is gonna have better empathy
uh and better managerial capabilities
for uh for their engineers.
Same with uh
designers and PMs.
Uh, we're seeing uh
um uh, you know, 7.4%
daily active use
uh for designers
and uh project managers.
Uh, and I, I don't think that's too surprising.
I mean like Figma.
Has one of the most powerful MCP servers
out there, like it's really, really good. And you
know, you can have project managers now. Canva's been
really public about
having uh their project managers,
uh, they've built a small agent that allows
project managers to uh natural language
what they want the product to do.
And then it goes into MCP via Figma
and it creates like a prototype, and it creates
like nice developer
friendly specifications.
So not only is it easier for the p.m.s to put
the PRDs together, but that translation
layer
of like what is this project requirement
supposed to do, and the developer actually being able to
understand that in their own vernacular is another
friction point that's been fixed by that
agent,
right? So, yeah, we have to really start rethinking
um.
Who's a developer in the organization anymore when
we're actually able to elevate traditional
non-builders and have them make contributions
like this. All right,
so that's a lot of good news.
But uh here is a very important point
that I think we all need to remember
is that
there are still so many pain points
for
engineers that have nothing to do with the
generation of code,
that are absolutely eclipsing
the time savings that we're seeing coming
from, you know, AI.
So when we annualize this, that pale
bar there in the middle is overall annualized
time savings
across, uh,
this is a sample of 134,000
developers.
Yeah, 134,000 developers.
That AI time savings, it's not insignificant,
but it is absolutely eclipsed by interruption, frequency,
so context switching throughout the day
from various sources,
uh, and, uh, meeting heavy days,
right? We, we all know that, right? What a
developer's always I have too many meetings, right?
There's some stuff that we can do around this that
that AI can help with.
You know, like going back to Zapier, they've reduced
their daily stand-ups from 5 days a week to
2 days a week, because they're doing like summary
of meetings and and change logs and things like
that, and using asynchronous updates instead
of running stand-ups.
But there's also some old school business stuff that
we can apply here too.
Like I'm a huge Ellie Goldrot theory of constraints
fan. And one of the thinking
models in the theory of constraints is something called
the evaporating cloud. And if you've not
heard about that before, it's definitely worth looking into.
It's a way of reducing
assumed dependencies
within an organization,
which can have the net effect of reducing the
number of meetings
in that organization. So there's non-AI
stuff and AI stuff that we can do to deal with
some of this. Interruption, frequency and
context switching, like I can't emphasize
enough
how detrimental this is to
organizational productivity.
There have been a number of studies.
One of them is called The Coding War Games. Anybody ever
read the book PeopleSoft?
Tom DeMarco, Timothy Lister,
great book. Totally still, this is one that I keep
in my desk, not even on my bookshelf, and I referenced
it a fair amount.
Um it was a series of studies that started in the, in
the late 70s.
And engineers took part
across about 100 organizations in the first study,
and there were about 700 engineers that
took place in this first study.
So you had engineers within a single organization
competing
in this study, and then you also had full
organizations competing against each other.
Now they found some really striking stuff.
First off was that
Across organizations, there was
an 11x difference in productivity.
You had some organizations that were 11 times
as productive as the lowest performing
organizations in the study.
Within a single organization, there was only
a 20% difference
between top performers and lower performers. Now
anybody familiar with systems thinking or profound knowledge
or the work of W. Edwards Demming,
this should not surprise you.
90 to 95% of the productivity
output of an organization is predicted by the system
and not the worker,
right? So what we see here is that even the most
amazing developers
are constrained by the systems and process and culture in
which they're working.
Some of the non-factors in the study were things
like language.
You know, people hypothesized, oh well, so they must be
using some really high performance, no,
the only, the the only lower performers really
in that study that were significant were assembly
developers.
Um, they thought that maybe salary
would be impacting this.
Only a 10% difference in salary between the highest
performers and the lowest performers in this study.
What they did find was when they answered
questions like, do people often interrupt
you needlessly?
The top performing organizations in that
study overwhelmingly had people say
no. So the
things like divert your phone calls, this is back in the day, we
had chunky conference phones and stuff like, but can
you divert, the same thing as Slack, Teams, anything
now. Like 5 times as many
people in the top performing
organizations answered positively that they could divert
their calls,
right? So this all came down to
like encouraging flow state,
minimizing context switching, like these
were the biggest indicators, and, and I think we're we're
still seeing this here, right? Where it's like, yeah, we're
getting some good time savings from AI
but our time syncs are still eclipsing that.
And there's stuff that we have to do with our system and our process and
our culture to fix that.
There's a well defined
neuroscience in place here too, and I, this
is part of why I love focusing on developer
experience. Um,
I've spent the last 7 years of my career or so just
singularly focused on developer experience, study, and
productivity,
and it's this wonderful
sort of confluence of
engineering and psychology and cognitive science
and neuroscience.
And there's a lot of really good details out there. There's a great
Scientific American article that came out,
um, just a few months ago,
that studied flow state in
like improv jazz guitarists.
They can go into flow state almost immediately.
And so of course we did what we did, we put brain caps on them
while they were playing guitar, try to figure out what what was
happening with them. And it was fascinating, like
we've all experienced flow, and we
know how productive we are in that state. We know that that's
our most, the highest innovative capability
and most creative time when we're experiencing flow, and
it feels good and it's satisfying work.
And what's happening is
long-term knowledge from the back of the brain
is getting shuffled into the prefrontal cortex,
and it's going back and forth and taking over some of the
executive functioning, which is where that timelessness
sort of comes from that we feel when we're in that state.
And we're flaring off norepinephrine and
dopamine and serotonin and all the great feel-good
neurotransmitters when we're doing that.
So the brain quite intentionally separates
work throughout the day
into these sort of chemical chapters of
flow
and then context switch.
So something interesting happens in the prefrontal cortex
when we get out of flow or are pulled out of flow.
The brain releases the glutamate neurotoxin
into the prefrontal cortex.
And says, OK, we're done with this chapter of work,
here's some glutamate. Then we reach a point
where we reach a threshold where we experience cognitive
fatigue.
Right? We have too much uh glutamate going on in the
prefrontal cortex, and so it's time to stop working
and get some rest. Or if we're gonna keep
working, it's not gonna be our best work.
Right? That's the funny thing about cognitive uh
fatigue,
especially in Western culture, like we're very productivity
focused, and so even when we're tired, we sometimes
still have to do work.
Um, but the thing is that it's really hard to
elevate that work, it's really hard to innovate,
it's really hard to be our most creative selves when
we're in that state of cognitive fatigue.
So a lot of the study of developer experience is really focusing
on how do we extend
these flow state chapters as long as we can.
To minimize context switching throughout the day,
to minimize the overall amount of of cognitive fatigue,
and it's, it's, it's kind of,
it's kind of weird to think about, but there's absolutely
a relationship
between, you know, a software-driven culture like
ours,
and the capacity for global innovation,
and the amount of context switching that our
engineers are having to deal with, right?
So I, I spend a lot of time on this because I think it's really,
really important, like we often kind of blow off this notion
of like, oh well, I just get slacks all day
and or I'm in too many meetings and it's like this
is, this is a big problem.
And it's not something that we can fully solve with
AI. So AI is great for a lot of things,
not a silver bullet. And there's some other time things
here too, like build and and and and test
time, right? I used to work for Gradle.
It was my first real foray into developer productivity
engineering. We focused a lot on interloop optimization,
like reducing build times, reducing test cycle times,
failure rates and stuff like that.
Still, I mean like you start combining some of these
things like developer environment, toil,
review wait time,
build and test uh cycle time, you start compounding
these, and they also eclipse the savings
that we're getting from
AI. OK,
uh, what about some things that really do save us
some time? So here's another study that we did,
uh, you're welcome to download.
Um, this was a study that we put together
where we wanted, you know, we started capturing AI
and ROI metrics a while ago in our platform.
And we wanted to just help, we
wanted to create a resource
that could help our customers see better ROI.
And of course we found overwhelmingly that education
and enablement had a lot to do with like making this
technology work really well.
So we did a study where we came
across engineers who were reporting at least 1 hour a
week of time savings when we did this, and
we surveyed them. And it was a very simple survey, it was
just like, please stack rank what you think your top 5
most valuable use cases are for AI.
And we did similar stuff with uh S Levels
who had already rolled out AIs like successfully to
thousands of engineers,
and we asked them to talk about what best practices
they were encouraging
uh and uh and what they're trying to encourage
their engineers to kind of teach each other to do.
And where we found commonality, we
included those best practices in this study, and
then we turned that, uh, you know, stack rank
your top 5
into this sort of top 10 list of
time saving use cases.
I think it's really interesting that stack trace analysis
was number one.
I mean now, you know, of course, like, you know, put
anything in agent mode and it's already kinda gonna do this for
you. Um this is another one of those
like philosophical points though, where it's like, I mean when
I was you know,
still a developer, but when I was writing code professionally
like in in the late 90s, early 2000s, there was a lot of Java.
And became more JEE stuff.
And then some spraying and things like that, which we
all know,
spit out terribly long stack traces
that were then sort of like going line by line through to
try to figure out what's going on. But it can be a bit of a puzzle,
like I mean as an engineer, sometimes you like to solve that
stuff. But this is another one where
it's like, no, you gotta give this over to the AI.
It does a great job with stack trace analysis, but I
think it's interesting that it's an interpretive use case
and not a generative use case.
We saw some other things here like refactoring existing
code. Yeah, absolutely.
Uh, mid-loop generation,
in other words, I'm gonna write the function header, and
then maybe do a comment about what this function is supposed
to do, and I'm gonna let you just fill in the middle
for me, right? Cause I'm still using my higher order
thinking, understanding what this function is supposed to do. I
don't really need to write the code in the middle.
Test case generation,
no-brainer, right?
Uh, learning new techniques.
Um,
another philosophical point that I get when I give a workshop
that's kind of, uh, designed around this, uh, guide,
people ask me about Justin, are,
are we actually learning?
And I think it's like a really
good question, right? I mean, for,
you know, I, for one, I mean like I was always directionally
challenged, but I can't get anywhere with my GPS, it's like impossible,
even my hometown and everything, I get lost,
uh, because I'm, you know, just,
just blindly following what the GPS is telling me to do.
Uh, is that what's happening with cogeneration?
The answer is maybe, and it's up to you,
right? Like this is your personal responsibility.
This isn't any different than like when we used to
copy paste code from Stack Overflow,
right? Like it's up to you at that point, like.
Do I wanna understand what this code is actually
doing?
Do I wanna learn and become a better developer, or
am I just in a rush and I have to hit the easy button?
So you absolutely can learn new stuff if
you so choose, right? And uh
so, you know, letting the agent just do
stuff and then just sort of trusting it, no, you
probably won't be learning.
But taking that extra moment uh to see
what's happening and try to understand what's happening,
not only will you generate better code in the long run,
but you'll become a better developer.
Uh, complex query writing.
So I, uh, when I give this workshop, and
I happen to be home on Zoom or something like that, I point
over to my bookshelf where my mastering
regular expressions book lives and
has not been cracked in ages, right?
I don't write regular expressions every day.
So getting the agent to do something that you don't
do every day, like a Projects
or feeding it some context about your schema
and having it generate SQL queries. Another
really good use case.
Certainly code documentation in multiple forms,
right? So, I'm one of those weird engineers who actually
does like writing longer form documentation
when I write code, but I hate commenting.
I know how important it is, right, for posterity
and everything, but I just want to kind of flow my way through
and then not have to worry about writing comments. These
things are great at inserting comments,
right? So we tend to think in terms of it like generating markup
and things like that, which is a very valid use case,
but auto-coming the code is really good too.
Uh, yeah, brainstorming and planning, one of my favorite
uh recursive workflows. This is now
a first-class citizen
in like cursor plan.
Amazon Quiro was one of the first to bring this to market.
I think it was the first to bring it to market as a first-class
citizen inside the IDE.
This is basically where you just say, OK, I'm a, you
know, computer programmer and you're a project manager.
Ask me one question at a time
about this thing that I wanna do, and then
create a specification based on our
conversation that I can then use to maybe scaffold code
or whatever.
This is one of those ones,
even, you know, as as reticent as I was at first,
that has completely changed the way that I work.
Right, I mean, you know, back in the day when I, when I was
writing code, you, you always miss something in
that early planning phase, and then you sit down to
code, and it bites you later,
right? This is a really great way to get that comprehensive
plan kind of out first. I think about it as kind of like
rubber ducking 2.0,
because it's like I'm discussing what I wanna do, but
I'm actually getting feedback, and then that feedback
is turned into a plan.
Uh, so I was very, very pleased to see that come out
in Amazon Kiiro when I started using the public
preview for it. Now of course it's made its way, uh feature
parody and other tools.
But yeah, I totally like this one too.
And you know, then code explanation, initial code scaffolding.
So yeah, uh, the guide itself is
about 65 pages long. It gets into
more than just these top 10, it gets into
prompting techniques like metap-prompting and
uh recursive prompt chaining and things like
that. Um, and so, uh,
you know, you can,
you know, use this as a reference if it's helpful for
your engineers. We've definitely had some organizations that
they're calling it like recursive
required reading now for their engineers.
But it's a good way also to get more ROI out of these
tools. OK,
speaking of ROI.
How should we be measuring all this stuff?
Uh, well,
Measuring productivity and even defining productivity
was already difficult.
And the engineering like landscape, the
industry had not already sort of
landed on
and aligned against and commoditized
the best way to do it.
And then AI came out.
And now we're trying to solve for measuring ROI
and productivity because we have people in,
you know, on, on,
we have people on the board and we have CTOs and stuff
asking for,
you know, what's the ROI that we're getting on all these massive
AI AI investments that we're making.
And the unfortunate truth is that a lot of us weren't
even good at measuring this before AI
and now we have a whole new factor
that's come in. But what I hope that does is actually
accelerate our, our paying attention
to this different ways to measure.
Um,
so even what we do at DX is not perfect, but I think
it's the best model, right? Again, we've kind of
combined Dora metrics with space
framework, with a metric framework called
Dev X which focuses on cognitive load,
it focuses on context switching, feedback loops.
So if you're doing the core 4, you're doing all three of those metric
sets at once.
And then it was kind of on us
to say, well, look, all of our customers now
want to understand the impact
that AI is having on
our productivity.
And so we're like, I really, we, we studied with a couple
of companies for a couple of months,
and then in sort of a fever dream state over
a long weekend,
myself and Abby, our CEO co-founder and
other CTO Laura, just like banged
this thing out, right? But based on data that we'd
pulled from the system and based on interviews and
things with other companies, I'll show you a few of them in a
moment. So, we
found out a few things, like, as we were kind of putting
this framework together.
Um, we kind of thought about
three different types of metrics
and kind of their strengths and kind
of their challenges, right?
So the first of course,
is our telemetry metrics,
right? Uh, this is getting stuff from
co-pilot API
or cursor API.
Uh, Anthropic and Cloud didn't have an API,
but we had customers who wanted to get that data, so we
worked directly with Anthropic to build their API
for Cloud, which is now in my opinion, like a really
good API.
Um, but there's not always like a full story
that's gonna come out of this, right?
What does utilization really mean?
Right, what does daily active use, weekly active use,
monthly active use really mean?
Forget accept versus suggested lines of
code. Lines of code was never a good metric to begin with.
I don't know why we think it would be good now.
Um, but, uh, um,
especially when, when, when we look at the fact that the only
way that the API knows if the code has been accepted
is if a button was clicked at the IDE and
there's still no way to tell after the fact that the
engineer didn't just go and rewrite every line of
code, uh, that was generated, right?
But it's OK for like understanding
like what's happening.
You know, it's OK for saying like like who, who is
kind of using this stuff and who, who seems
to be like using it more than others.
Um,
but it's not until we start getting into what we
call our impact metrics,
right? How does this cohort, some of the trends
that I've already shown you, like, how does a cohort
or usage correlate to
PR throughput or PR merge rates,
or code confidence, uh change confidence,
or change failure rate. So speed and
quality metrics, right? Now we can actually start correlating
this stuff, right? And so it's, it's useful for
that. Experience sampling
can be great for collecting
small bits of data
and starting to quantify some ROI.
So this is, for instance, like interrupting a developer
as they're already in a workflow, but hopefully
not in a way that causes a context switch. So like for
instance, a great example, good textbook example
is adding one additional field to a PR
form, where they're already having to fill out a
PR that says, I used
AI to work on this PR.
Or I enjoyed
using AI to work on this PR,
right? We get that one little piece of data.
Uh, it can be a little difficult to set up though, and
we have to run this over a period of time, right? We wanna get longitudinal
data, uh, from this to kind of
understand that impact.
Then finally, self-reported data, surveys.
Um, again, we're a little biased, we've
done a great job of engineering our surveys and we get
great participation rates in our surveys.
Um, but when you do this, these signals
can be incredibly strong. I was just talking to, uh,
Uh, someone at Slack who gave a talk
at the same uh little event that I was doing a few hours
ago here in the Wynn,
and, uh, Slack relies mostly on
the qualitative signals that they get, because they get
like 92, 93% participation
rates in their engineering surveys.
When you get that high, and when it's a well engineered
survey, we even say like trust the qualitative
metrics over the system metrics. Like
you need both to understand what's fully happening,
but if there's like a deviation.
Where it's like the system metrics seem to
be telling you something that's different than the qualitative
metrics. When you have that good strong signal,
we're like, yeah, trust the qualitative metrics and figure out
what's wrong with the system metrics, right?
So that's where the self-reported data comes in, but we all know,
you know, they can't, they can only be run periodically.
We really don't wanna, we really don't want survey fatigue,
you know, we feel like quarterly is about right. The
real number
is how long it takes for improvements
to flow through your organization, and that's gonna
change based on your culture,
cause the last thing you wanna do is keep running these surveys
that just never change,
right? What you wanna be able to do to get engineers
excited about taking surveys and providing feedback
is showing
that the audience is looking at these signals
and saying, OK, great, thank you for this feedback.
Here's what we're gonna prioritize improving over
the next 3 months, 6 months, whatever
that is. Then we're gonna benchmark again and
say, OK, well did this actually move the needle. Then you have
engineers that figure out, OK, well actually this feedback is kind
of making my life better and I kinda like it.
So that's how we end up in these nice flywheels of of continuous
improvement. Uh, so yeah, telemetry
metrics, experience sampling and self-reported
data, and we really recommend that you do all three,
right? Cause each of them are gonna do different things and
give you a full picture.
This is the measurement framework itself.
So again, this was the result of working with a number of
companies, as well as what we already knew about
productivity.
You can use this measurement framework
in a few different ways.
Uh, in one way it's just like looking at
the raw metrics,
understanding what metrics are important. None of this was done
in a vacuum.
These all represent metrics that
across, uh, close to 40 different
companies that we ended up looking at what they were paying attention
to. We found commonality and we put them
in the framework.
But it's also inspired by the space
framework,
in that it's not just metrics,
it's dimensions, and more importantly, oppositional
dimensions.
Right? One good, great way to think about
um good metrics,
and this is not me, this is the author of the Space
Framework, Margaret Ann's story, Peggy's story's a good
friend, is to look at
a constellation of metrics
in tension with one another, right?
And so that's why we always map these uh these metrics
into these oppositional dimensions,
utilization, impact and cost.
You can also think about this as a maturity curve,
right? Most organizations are starting on
the left.
They're getting utilization like daily active use,
weekly active use, the percentage of PRs that are AI
assisted. And then as we start gathering
those, you know, what's going on metrics,
we move into the impact metrics, and some of these
should look familiar if you're already doing like Dora or
if you're familiar with the core 4.
So these are things like developer satisfaction,
PR throughput, perceived rate of delivery,
uh, changed confidence, change failer
percentage.
Um, so we want to start again being able to correlate
this. And then of course
cost. I mean, I do like to point out
that we're 15 years past the last major hype
cycle, and we're still figuring out how to
control our cloud costs
in a lot of cases, why a lot of us are here.
Um, but I'm also hearing horror stories
about engineers burning through like $3000 worth
of tokens a day,
so we are gonna have to get a handle on this. But what
we're finding is that in that maturity curve, it tends
to be like the utilization metrics first, followed by
the impact metrics, and then these cost metrics.
OK, so that's the framework. Lots of ways to gather
this data,
uh, just like space framework, we don't really prescribe
how to gather the data,
more that you normalize the data
into these dimensions.
So these are just a couple of the companies
that we worked with uh to um
put this framework together,
uh, and some of the metrics that were important to them.
So Microsoft,
looking at adoption just like Dropbox, just
like booking, so some commonality there for
adoption metrics.
Microsoft looking at things like system velocity, developer
satisfaction, change failure rate,
and one of my favorite metrics of all time.
We don't have time to go into this right now,
but it's called a bad developer day. Uh,
Microsoft is a great white paper on this if you look up
the Microsoft bad developer days.
Um, and it's basically like gathering telemetry
from a whole bunch of different areas,
uh, of the workflow,
and putting together signals that said, yeah, this developer
had a bad day, like too many meetings
or too many incidents, and there's a lot of
different metrics in there.
But then they're correlating this to AI utilization,
and look that one up, it really is kind of cool.
Um, Dropbox,
who has been hyperfocused on developer
experience
since the beginning.
Their CEO opens up the DX
platform every morning
to look at how developer productivity metrics
and experience metrics are going.
Uh, they're looking at adoption,
they're looking at developer sentiment, velocity as well,
percentage of uh AI code lines that were
added versus the total lines added.
Quality, they look at change failure percentage. Change failure
rate's a great metric, tells us so many different stories
about what's happening with quality in the organization.
And then Booking.com, yeah, daily active use, weekly
active use, overall time, say, PR throughput.
So you see some commonality here,
and where you see this overlap, this is how we put this metric
framework together. So this is pretty well trusted,
like these metrics have now been validated, not
just in our platform across millions of
developers and data points and things like this, but
across other companies too.
Uh, so,
there's no way you can read that.
That's, that's another set.
Uh, maybe you zoom in on your phone or rather look at it later. It's
also in that guide, uh, that I mentioned before.
Um,
but these are just some, what some other companies are looking at as
well. Uh, so GitHub, Toast,
uh, Grammarly.
But again, I really wanna stress here
that AI metrics again,
measure what's happening.
But core metrics measure whether
these investments are working,
right? And they're
really, those haven't really changed, right? I mean
we still are looking at speed, uh velocity,
but also quality.
But I think it's important that we understand that
hyperfocusing on any metric, like we said
before with Cobra effect and Goodheart's law is bad.
But um only looking at utilization
metrics are not going to tell you the full picture. They're
not gonna tell you whether the investments are actually
working. That's what the core foundation metrics are
for. All right,
so in summary,
um, you know, we do want to, as I mentioned
before, avoid venture lock-in, like, you know,
these tools are leapfrogging each other.
Uh, we want to expand the definition
of a developer.
We want to measure AI adoption.
Hopefully, uh, this framework was was
interesting, or at least some good food for thought about what you can be
measuring. But also remember that AI is not
a silver bullet,
right? That even though we're seeing these time savings in some
places, those time savings are often being
eclipsed
by uh other sources of friction, toil,
context switching and things like that from developers.
So final resource I'll share with you, uh,
a lot of this is summarized, the measurement
aspect is summarized in this uh strategy
playbook for senior executives.
Um, we get into a lot of stuff in
this guide.
We get into how to think about integrating
across the SDLC. I mentioned I love Ellie Goldrot,
means I also love value stream mapping.
So there's a lot of, uh,
information in here and how you can use your value stream maps to
determine where uh agentic AI is really
gonna help you. I dive a lot into psychological
safety. I talk about Google's Project Aristotle,
where they ran this study where they had this hypothesis
that the most performative, like highly. Forming teams
were going to be a result of like really good management
and really great developers and unlimited
compute resources, and they were totally wrong.
And what they actually found out was that psychological safety
was overwhelmingly the most important factor
in a high performing team. And I think that's more
important now than ever with AI.
Uh, we'll get into things like, you know, compliance, trust,
uh, security,
and we'll get into how we can sort of tie.
Um, you know, these skill sets
to employees' success, right?
And really try to remind employees that
you're, you're giving them an opportunity,
uh, to learn about something that again will
likely benefit them for the rest of their
career. And that's all I have for you today. Thank you
very much.